dans le domaine économique le canton de
sainte marie aux mines est en contact
direct avec les pôles urbains de colmar
de sélestat voire de sat de saint dié il
bénéficie d'une forte attractivité
touristique avec des retombées positives
sur le plan économique et de l'emploi
la viticulture y joue est également un
rôle essentiel en employant une
main-d'oeuvre locale importante notre
canton dispose aussi de zone d'activité
où sont installés des entreprises
performantes et dynamique
nous nous trouvons dans la zone
d'activités du muhlbach qui est géré par
un syndicat intercommunal qui regroupe
les communes de ribeauvillé de guémar et
de bercail ce syndicat qui a été créée
pour accueillir une unité française du
groupe sony c'est et s'est étendue au
fil des années et accueille aujourd'hui
une vingtaine d'entreprises
supplémentaires qui emploie près de 700
salariés
une pépinière d'entreprises a été créé
par deux syndicats en 2010 elle est
constituée de cet atelier est de 6
bureaux qui sont occupées par de jeunes
créateurs d'entreprise une nouvelle
extension de cette zone d'accueil
nomique vient d'être achevée elle
s'étend sur 7 hectares supplémentaires
découpé en 10 partiel qui sont
entièrement viabilisés et équipés de la
fibre optique
l'ensemble de ces travaux et de ces
investissements ont bénéficié d'une aide
financière du conseil départemental du
haut rhin dans le cadre des contrats de
territoire de vie et du soutien au
développement économique territorial le
canton de sainte-marie-aux-mines connaît
une croissance du nombre de personnes
âgées supérieur à la moyenne
départementale
elle devrait encore s'accentuer au cours
des années à venir
ce vieillissement de notre population
nécessite la mise en place de mesures
d'accompagnement
le conseil départemental du haut-rhin
intervient en faveur des aînés dans
plusieurs domaines 2 pôle gérontologique
celui de kaysersberg lapoutroie et celui
de ribeauvillé sainte-marie-aux-mines
permettent d'accueillir d'informer ou
d'orienter les personnes âgées de 60 ans
et plus le service des prestations
sociales du conseil départemental a en
charge l'instruction et des demandes
pour les aides sociales ou l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie
par ailleurs notre canton dispose de
treize structures offrant près de près
de 950 places d'hébergement permanent ou
temporaire aux personnes qui ne peuvent
plus rester à domicile
nous sommes ici à l'ehpad intercommunal
des fraxinelle à bergheim un nouvel
établissement qui a été inauguré en juin
2015 et qui est issu de la fusion des
deux maisons de retraite de
saint-hippolyte et de bergheim cette
nouvelle construction a bénéficié d'une
subvention du conseil départemental du
haut rhin et d'une aide financière de l'
agence régionale de la santé
elle nous permet d'accueillir dans les
meilleures conditions 120 résidents dont
14 en unité spécifique pour les malades
d'alzheimer
d'autres projets sont à l'étude d'autres
cantons l'agrandissement de la maison
médicalisée du canton vert à orbey le
regroupement sur un site des ehpad de
sainte croix et de
sainte-marie-aux-mines et la
construction d'une nouvelle résidence
qui réunira les ehpad de kaysersberg et
d'amour fuir ces projets permettront eux
aussi d'améliorer la qualité de
l'accueil et des soins des personnes
dépendantes et de mieux répondre aux
besoins et aux attentes de nos aînés et
de leurs familles